gérard depardieu bonsoir merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
c'est un maurice pialat très touchant
très émouvant très meurtrie qu'on
découvre dans ce dans ce documentaire on
se demande un peu pourquoi le cinéma
français ne lui a pas si le crédit de
cet aspect de sa personnalité pourquoi
on a plutôt retenu là l'aspect un peu
ours sauvage j'avais déjà les bières
c'est à dire que j'avais beaucoup de mal
à l'entendre à le comprendre maurice
comme tous les gens qui rayonnait qui
avait une grande générosité humanité on
peut dire entre guillemets que c'était
un monstre donc comme il aimait
monstrueusement comme il répondait
monstrueusement aussi en revanche sur le
poing levé ce fameux point levé ce qui
l'a obligé à dire bien puisque voilà je
suis surtout content que vous puissiez
que je sois sifflé puisque vous ne
m'aimez pas je ne vous aide pas non plus
ça vient d'un profond malentendu parce
qu'il était d'abord ce film le soleil de
satan de bernanos était très difficile
pour lui à faire ils voulaient pas le
tour b
combien de fois il m'a demandé de le
tourner le jeu parce que finalement
c'est bien amusés entre guillemets oui
parce que dans tous les films où il ya
beaucoup de douleur
et bien finalement on s'amuse mais le
seul qui a souffert également jeu daniel
toscan du plantier qui avait du mal
avant ce film c'est terminé il n'en
pouvait plus il y en a un autre parent
dont williams s'est interrogé après
cette escale ont été extrêmement fatigué
est ce que maurice pialat souffrait de
ce manque de reconnaissance
c'est à dire qu'il se hisse à infligé
lui-même il était le premier à ne pas se
reconnaître non plus il était toujours
ou autre on avance outre port tard c'est
vraiment l'archétype même d'un artiste
comme un artiste peintre c'est quelqu'un
qui pouvait tout à fait faire comme
bonnart à les retoucher cinq toiles dans
le musée il ne pouvait pas aider jamais
satisfait de sa toile terminé c'est
jamais satisfait ni de son jeu d'acteur
ni de sa direction d'acteurs
jeu d'acteur le nord bad le comédien le
jeu d'acteur moi j'ai fait à temps par
l'ancien bt mais j'ai dirigé il m'a
demandé de j'ai préféré que ce soit lui
qui joue benot s'exerce la baie mais en
ce qui me concerne moi j' mais c'est
vrai qu'il est et il est exigeant avec
les as pas exigeant et fallait tomber
des masques tout le temps alors il ya
des gens qui pourraient être plus ou
moins supporter il a eu des mots très
durs pour la nouvelle vague
dans ce film c'était une critique
distancié où c'était une envie d'en
faire partie
dans la nouvelle vague il en faisait
partie il avait dit ils aimaient
beaucoup truffaut bon ils n'étaient pas
c'est quelqu'un qui me remettait
toujours en question l'honnêteté de des
gens qui font ce métier c'est vrai que
quand on voit aussi calme c'est très
difficile dit hier je voyais les 60
réalisateur l'anniversaire les 35
donateurs quand on voit c'est assez
monstrueux d'ailleurs c'est ça qui était
très beau à voir aussi tousser beterz en
scène ses actrices une honnêteté
complète en prime oui mais en même temps
quand ils l'avaient ils en étaient pas
contents ça c'était l'un satisfait
permanent merci gérard depardieu donc
l'amour existe documentaire qui sort le
30 mai